the popular kids birthday destination  chuck-e-cheese you know them right well  they think oh yeah chucky cheese has  announced that they are getting rid of  their famous animatronic band yes well  we've discussed many world topics  tonight so far this is the one that has  you most outraged that says so much  about us right now and I'm with you I'm  not judging we've talked about  Afghanistan and rallies and protests in  Phoenix now people are true though the  chuck-e-cheeses are getting rid of all  of their animatronic bands all of them  and it is really sad I mean you can see  how the decision has affected morale  around the Chucky Cheese restaurants  check it out hey maybe 40 years yeah I  can barely feel the knife in my back  now here's an old song with some brand  new changes  [Music]  I'm on three antidepressant  [Music]  kids against what I took the biggest  [ __ ] in the ball pit  [Music]  [Applause]  you